bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here airplane James is in the building
yes sir Easter new project coming still
hurt 111. so yeah so this will come out
Friday so so if you're watching this
you can go get the album right now yeah
yeah all that let's go hey man
appreciate you pulling up it's been a
long time coming yes sir who's on the
album I got Jason cash I got Kate
Franklin
please don't let me forget anybody Griff
Tyler rose gold nope and that's about it
Jason cash is a great great guy I [ __ ]
with Jason guys solid human being yes I
love that guy all right well look we're
just gonna have you do what you do go
get the uh you said the Project's called
East up no it's called still hurt still
hurt okay you said East up I'm not
tripping though I just want to make sure
I'm not tripping that's just my greeting
so what you said people say what's up I
say Easter I respect it uh airplane
James is in the building man he came
here to do what he does let's do it bro
all right
look I can't receive some new [ __ ]
were double back I'm Petty like that
came about the 80s when [ __ ] show you
who like that wrote Love Letters to
Jazzy machine right back I'm big dog
status now all you [ __ ] cap and gown
[ __ ] man get out with your [ __ ] had
your [ __ ] catch my [ __ ] fade I come
from that go through any Hood 50s to the
hundreds boy I bet they bumping that
giving problems out whoever wanted that
hanging out with Yak see my granny never
wanted that but I ain't here peep I'm on
them pigs up the street see them [ __ ]
cross the street one of them I gotta
sleep I dodged murder every week I see
murder in the street I see kids
Hopscotch over it ain't missing beat off
of 83rd Street put them boys on the
seven love them and every time I slide
through I chunk up seven of them I Gotta
Give it up [ __ ] wanna see me pick my
Pivot up so I can make the wrong move I
never cry about it but I make sure the
song do and I made my own rules I never
had the gang bang but like them boys on
98th Street I gotta maintain look care
I'm really like that yeah just gotta let
you know now we can get off that I got
it been a brim on this Detroit Tiger
ball cap I gotta be in uniform for I
give you these hard facts bird gave me
the keys I gotta try this [ __ ] she said
she like airplane we'll come and fly
this [ __ ] I've been putting rappers on
the plate for a while how you think I
got my weight up but clean diet [ __ ]
[ __ ] mention my name step in the
Lion's Den if you don't wanna fight or
shoot it out then be quiet then and
while we on the topic God get offended
cause from this diamond lane [ __ ] you
know I'm a descendant and they ain't
give us what we owe dawg so I'm here to
mend it posting money on the ground but
these [ __ ] don't spend it um
this gonna be a light scrimmage Seal's
Still Standing when I get finished
Hershey's sucking dick for a verified
mention where they just blue check me up
you can get a mention my DM's looking I
don't even want to talk about it this
for the times I had to go in cop a teeth
and fires walk in that [ __ ] see what I
could get for five dollars Thirty days
left on the sentence and still crack the
riot my granny sent me up the road to
Kim Kilpatrick [ __ ] with me his ass
backwards I can put them G's on your
head [ __ ] now you play for the Packers
I've been doing this [ __ ] since I used
to ditch Miss balance yeah I rap like
I'm from man why but I'm from the coast
black star when I'm bald [ __ ] I do the
most cheers to be in that [ __ ] had your
[ __ ] through the toast serenade a [ __ ]
and kill a rapper I do them both and we
ain't splitting up the bread [ __ ] cause
I bring a loaf and I kill a [ __ ] quick
I never claim and be woe you ever seen
50 [ __ ] from different hoods coexist
you ever seen a [ __ ] as cold as this
diamond lane for 365 bro I swear you
gonna feel my pain take a chunk out your
neck this block got face [ __ ] whoo
foreign
[ __ ] still hurt out now I didn't knock
over the weekend over the pound cause
I'm that [ __ ] tight yes hey
look bro that was crazy
yeah stop playing with me new album out
right now yes sir all that pressure
kicking the year off on the freestyle
series man come on bro stop playing with
me top five on anything what's your
socials man let everybody know airplane
354 on Twitter airplane James 354 on
Instagram that's all I got that was hard
hey what up y'all appreciate you guys
watching this week's freestyle we're
dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half okay at checkout
that's right all right shout out to LRG
one more time L Dash R Dash g.com and
when you check out use that promo code
bootleg and save 30 off the freestyles
we'll be back next week always brought
to you by LRG baby